hey what's up this is GQ recommends
today we're going to be talking about
seven iconic boots
[Music]
the boots we chose today all really
fulfill a certain need in your wardrobe
work boots hiking boots weatherproof
boots and then on top of that they also
look really good each of these boots are
iconic in their own way if you're not
sure where to start this is going to be
a good resource for that you'll see boot
Trends flare up and they'll be cool for
a season or two we really tried to think
outside of that these are boots that
would have been cool in 1972 they would
have been cool in 2002 and they're still
very cool in 2022 and Beyond
Red Wing classic Mach 6-inch boot
they've been around for a long time for
good reason these guys started out
actually doing some hard labor they're
known for having a break-in process so
they're really sturdy Red Wing makes
their own uh Leathers as well so that's
something special that you won't see
everywhere this thick wedge sole is
super comfortable kind of helps offset
the break-in period and it's a boot that
is made to last it's made for hard
wearing but it also looks great with a
pair of jeans a pair of chinos even if
you're not doing hard manual labor these
aren't gonna serve you well and for a
long time yeah they are like a classic
All-American boot I bought a pair of
these like 12 years ago still wear them
all the time the leather is held up
beautifully over time you know like I've
worn them through slush through rain and
the great part about them too is that
they're fully resoldable you can just
bring get to a cobbler and they can pop
it right off and so a new one right on
and you'll be good to go another classic
work boot option is the Timberland six
inch wheat boot that's another one that
uses fully waterproof it's built to
withstand really intense working
conditions it'll last you a long time
it's great in all sorts of weather and
looks good with a ton of things in your
wardrobe
Danner Mountain light boots
those Red Wing work boots aren't quite
your Vibe then this is another very
strong very weatherproof very versatile
option also made in America it's from
Danner which is a brand out of Portland
Oregon they have that very very classic
hiking style if you're picturing a
hiking boot or like an alpine boot this
is probably the one that comes to mind
the style was a big hit when they
introduced it in the 70s a lot of
similar hiking Alpine boots came after
that it was the first one to be
waterproof and it uses Gore-Tex it's
still breathable but also will keep the
water out which is something you
definitely want on the trails but they
also just look sick absolutely not on
the trail this lacing style is very bold
and maybe it's not for everyone but
these are way more versatile than you
might think whether you're wearing a
fleece cool hiking pants that kind of
thing you see guys in Italy wear these
with a suit all the time like with a
nice final suit a pair of boots like
this really goes off and really looks
sick despite how like
Hefty they look they're pretty
comfortable it's right there in the name
Mountain light Mountain light exactly I
mean out of the boots that we've chosen
today this is probably the one I would
wear every day
Merrell Moab to hiking boot
so if the danners represent sort of the
Nay plus Ultra of hiking boots this is
the modern equivalent why are the
Merrell moabs like the goat hiking boot
in your opinion they've got a lot of
tech behind them I mean they've got a
crazy Vibram soul for you to grip
anything it's like a four-wheel drive
Subaru for you oh totally yeah I mean
it's also waterproof and it's very light
it's super comfortable it does feel a
lot like a sneaker and it looks like a
sneaker in that kind of dadish way
that's really cool right now you know
what I mean they're very much of their
era which is you know the late 90s early
2000s even more so than the danners the
performance aspect here is really cool
in the spectrum of boots that we're
talking about today these are among the
most affordable oh yeah you can get them
for as as little as under a hundred
dollars in some cases these are the Moab
twos Merrell just came out with the Moab
3 which they're really pushing which
means you can get some great deals on
the Moab too yeah totally I mean the
mother of all boots one of the goats
it's kind of crazy that you can buy a
pair of these for the same price or even
cheaper than you know a lot of sneakers
during the pandemic as people were
endeavoring to get outdoors more there's
been a real explosion in people
embracing outdoorsy sort of techy
clothes you're seeing a lot more
style-minded people Embrace a shoe that
looks like these Merrell moabs the first
person that comes to mind for me is
Frank Ocean yeah showing up to
Fashion Week all like kitted out in
waterproof clothing and like hiking
boots so it's not just for you know uh
Avid hikers it looks cool you know in
the streets and it is very practical I
would say like you know if you're the
kind of guy that likes wearing New
Balance 990s old school A6 Runners these
are the boots for you right they have a
very similar energy very similar Vibe
they're going to go with a lot of the
same kinds of clothes you would wear
those sneakers with and you know they
had the added bonus of being able to
handle whatever weather you want to
throw at them L.L bean original eight
inch Bean boot they may not look like it
but these might actually be the hottest
hypest boots that we're talking about
today the bean boot has a tendency to
sell out very quickly every winter every
fall because they are maybe the best
weatherproof boot on the planet you're
going to want to pair these on your side
to like get you through the muck with
dry warm not soggy feet some of the
other boots that we've talked about are
waterproof the nice thing about these is
this lower half is rubberized so even if
you do find yourself in a puddle or you
know a Balenciaga show right you can
just hose this off these are another
like really really standard staple boot
that a lot of people grew up wearing you
know they go well with a lot of those
kind of old school Staples right like
they look great with an Oxford shirt
some chinos corduroy pants corduroy
pants their old school construct
production still really holds up to
Modern standards I'd say and they still
make them in Maine which I think is part
of the reason they sell out they can't
make a ton of them they're not like
super super mass produced at this point
still if you're lucky enough to get your
hands on them because they are quite
affordable and a really good value you
absolutely should and do it before
winter comes but that's right I mean
people forget and they're like oh now
it's winter I don't have boots yeah when
the first big blizzard hits in December
or January wherever you live uh these
guys will be gone they make a lot of uh
versions of this this is probably the
most classic one but they're even taller
ones or slightly shorter ones there's
some that come with like a wool lining
or a shearling lining lining if it gets
really cold there are a lot of different
versions of it for the weather you're
experiencing Tom Brown Pebble grain
wingtip boot in a sort of hard left from
the previous boot we were talking about
is this pair from Tom Brown this one is
something he puts out every season
and for good reason it's really handsome
the silhouette's nice these are probably
not as like substantial or hardcore as
like some of the other boots we've
talked about but they are definitely
sturdier and more winter appropriate
than just a standard pair of dress shoes
they're made of this really gorgeous
Pebble grain leather which is
notoriously like quite tough and like
can stand up to quite a bit and still
have that really really refined elegant
dress shoe-esque look they're Sleek but
at the same time not dainty I feel like
that's mostly because of the the soul
which is pretty substantial these are
going to go great with a suit or with
some dress pants and they're way more
versatile than that as well like I would
totally wear these with a pair of jeans
on the weekend you could pull these off
with a whole wide variety of looks and
they're gonna look great
so you know in the event that you don't
have that Tom Brown money then a great
option is solo there these are made in
England boots they used to be the makers
of Doc Martens and they still make these
wonderful brogues that have a work boot
s quality to them but are still very
very in that dressy upscale mode
Saint Laurent Wyatt Chelsea on the
extreme other end of the spectrum from
where we started the Saint Laurent
Chelsea boots are super Sleek they're
really not meant for any kind of bad
weather or anything along those lines
these are made for going out for looking
and feeling awesome for feeling like a
badass Chelsea boots were really
cemented into pop cultural history in
the 60s they were called the beetle boot
they've sort of been associated with
rock ever since and you can kind of see
why right I've actually never handled a
pair of these yeah and the details are
pretty crazy sailor raw makes These
Boots constantly they are a staple of
the Saint Laurent line and as a result
they come in a lot of really cool
makeups like a gleaming patent leather
that will look great with a tux you can
get them in like an extremely cool
crushed velvet if you're not totally
psyched about spending you know a grand
and or whatever on a pair of shoes
another option we like is from a brand
called RM Williams they've been around
for a long time making boots in
Australia and have sort of become this
real icon of this style of Chelsea boot
they are also still very slim and
sculptural and have like a very similar
effect to the Saint Laurent but they're
not as flashy they're like a little bit
more restrained a little more toned down
and you know maybe a little bit more
practical too which is great takovis the
Johnny
the last boot we're talking about is a
cowboy boot this brand to gobus is a
newcomer to the game but I think
honestly one of the best examples of
like Adidas
the quality is really great the price is
what you want but you're getting a lot
out of it there's a lot of traditional
techniques that go into this that really
make it a classic cowboy boot and I love
the suede upper they have them in a
bunch of different materials but this
suede is going to look so good worn in
these are very practical if you're
riding a horse yeah I was gonna say like
I actually own these exact cowboy boots
and I bought them because last year I
went on a trip with some friends out to
New Mexico and we had like a whole
cowboy experience so I can say from
experience that you know for actual
Cowboy duties these cowboy boots hold up
they are kind of a swerve that's why we
sort of are talking about them last like
they're definitely not as practical as
you know like the Duck Boots we were
talking about or as dressy as the Tom
Browns they kind of stand out from the
crowd but they're like well worth the
effort if you're looking to take your
boot game in a whole new Direction it's
a great everyday boot it's a great
flashy boot also so I like that there
are no laces I don't have to waste my
time they're slipping straight on you're
wearing sort of like a variation on a
cowboy boot right now right Gerald yeah
totally uh this is a pull-on boot from a
brand called fry this one in particular
is called their campus boot they have
this square toe which I like a lot I
think something like the cowboy boots or
the boots I'm wearing it's hard for me
to imagine a pair of pants that
won't go with it they're both like very
versatile and very eye-catching and bold
at the same time
[Music]
foreign
so those are all the boots that we're
going to be running through today
there's a lot to like I think they're
all really easy to style which is why we
chose them but do you have a favorite I
mean yeah I think I'm a little partial
because you know I actually do own these
exact boots
um they're a favorite of mine so that's
probably my my very favorite do you have
one yeah you took it
but I also really like the danners
that's probably the second one that I
would wear like all the time one day
when I can afford those Saint laurents
I'm going to do it and you will see me
stunning everywhere I look forward to
that what's great about all these boots
is that you know they come in such a
range of prices and styles like
hopefully you guys found something worth
investing in It's Gonna fit your
lifestyle and fit your style well said
thanks for tuning in